- [Voiceover] Let f of x
equal negative x squared
plus a x plus b
over x squared plus c x plus d
where a, b, c, and d
are unknown constants.
Which of the following is a possible graph
of y is equal to f of x?
And they told us dashed
lines indicate asymptotes.
So this is really interesting here.
And they gave us four choices.
We see four of them,
three of them right now.
Then if I scroll over bit over,
you can see choice D.
And so I encourage you to pause the video
and think about how we can figure it out
because it is interesting
because they haven't
given us a lot of details.
They haven't given us
what these coefficients
or these constants are going to be.
All right, now let's think about it.
So one thing we could think about is
horizontal asymptotes.
So let's think about what happens
as x approaches positive
or negative infinity.
Well, as x, so as x approaches
infinity or x approaches
negative infinity, f of x.
F of x is going to be
approximately equal to.
Well, we're going to look
at the highest degree terms
because these are going to dominate
as the magnitude of x,
the absolute value of
x becomes very large.
So f of x is going to be
approximately negative x squared
over x squared which is equal to negative
or we could another way to think about it.
This is the same thing as negative one.
So f of x is going to approach,
f of x is going to approach negative one.
In either direction, as
x approaches infinity
or x approaches negative infinity.
So we have a horizontal asymptote
at y equals negative one.
Let's see, choice A here,
it does look like they
have a horizontal asymptote
at y is equal to negative one
right over there.
And we can verify that
because each hash mark is two.
We go from two to zero
to negative two to negative four.
So this does look like
it's a negative one.
So just based only on
the horizontal asymptote,
choice A looks good.
Choice B, we have a horizontal asymptote
at y is equal to positive two.
So we can rule that out.
We know that a horizontal asymptote
as x approaches positive
or negative infinity
is at negative one,
y equals negative one.
Here, our horizontal asymptote is
at y is equal to zero.
The graph approaches,
it approaches the x axis
from either above or below.
So it's not the horizontal asymptote.
It's not y equals negative one.
So we can rule that one out.
And then similarly, over here,
our horizontal asymptote is
not y equals negative one.
Our horizontal asymptote
is y is equal to zero
so we can rule that one out.
And that makes sense
because really they only
gave us enough information
to figure out the horizontal asymptote.
They didn't give us enough information
to figure out how many roots
or what happens in the interval
and all of those types of things.
How many zeros and all that
because we don't know what the actual
coefficients or constants
of the quadratic are.
All we know is what happens as
the x squared terms dominate.
This thing is going to
approach negative one.
And so we picked choice A.